997 days after January 6th 2021 we
finally have evidence of an Insurrection
at the US capital the Insurrection did
not come by way of any horn hat wearing
Shaman smiling lecturn movers or even
Midwestern Granny's the Insurrection
came by way of democrat Congressman
Jamal Bowman who was caught on camera
pulling the fire alarm at the Cannon
House Office Building just before a
motion to adjourn as Democrats sought
desperately some more desperately than
others apparently to delay A continuing
resolution vote for those who are
unfamiliar with Jamal Bowman he is a
Democrat from New York who once called
me a quote Nazi hellbent on keeping only
white men alive and in power end quote
because I said
that he is a little eccentric you could
say a little excitable and now
apparently by democrat's own logic an
insurrectionist on January sorry on
January 6 the worst day in the history
of this already Republic of 2021 Nancy
Pelosi was the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and for years after that
Nancy Pelosi withheld video footage
exonerating many of the January 6ers
footage for instance showing the horn
hat guy being escorted through the
capital by police
officers now Republican Kevin McCarthy
is the speaker of the house and so we
have seen right away proof of Jamal
Bowman pulling the alarm and attempting
to disrupt the
motion Congressman Bowman has been
caught on camera doing much more to
obstruct an official Congressional
proceeding than any of the prominent
January Sixers certainly more than the
horn hat guy the horn hat guy got 41
months in prison if there is anything
even remotely resembling a fair system
of justice in the United States
Congressman Bowman should be wearing an
orange jumpsuit for at least as long I'm
Michael nolles this the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
doesn't look good when you pull fire
alarms in the US capital when you do
want to look good you got to check out
genus cell skincare this episode is
brought to you by jus cell say hello to
the best skin you've ever had with the
Jus cell darkspot corrector get yours at
Jus cell.com
noes speaking of our nation's capital we
might get a thirdparty candidate for
president and one of of the most serious
third party challengers in a very long
time we'll get to that in a second first
though before we move on from Congress
AOC is defending Congressman Bowman he
says it was an accident he thought
pulling the alarm would open a door uh
based on the fact that the doors to his
right there were locked and there was a
sign that he said he was I think someone
said it was confusing I'll be honest
that doesn't really make sense to me his
explanation have you talked to
him what's going on there I mean listen
I think if you actually do see some of
the photos of the signs I think there's
there's something to be said about the
government's about to shut down there's
a vote clock that's going down the exits
that are normally open in that building
were suddenly closed he pull the fire
alarm so I'm I'm what I am here to say
is that house administration and US
capital police and Jamal Bowman are an
active and he's fully participating and
saying there was a misunderstanding but
what I do think is important to raise is
the fact that Republicans
Representatives like Nicole malakis and
others immediately moved to file motions
to censure motions to expel before there
before there has even been conversations
that are that are finished to even see
if there was a misunderstanding here we
just need to go a little bit slower here
I mean I know we rounded up every single
Midwestern granny that was even within a
100 miles of Washington DC on January
6th but here where we have clear footage
of this Congressman obstructing a
congressional proceeding by pulling a
fire alarm here we just need to slow
walk this until everyone forgets okay
cuz come on he just didn't know this is
the most amazing excuse that we're
getting out of AOC even Jake Tapper here
says what hold you're telling me the guy
couldn't read a clear sign and so he
pulls a fire alarm to get out of the
building give me a break but but this is
now the line that the Democrats are
sticking with Chris Hayes on MSNBC
reposted a picture of what was allegedly
the signs that Congressman Bowman was
seeing and the signs said emergency exit
push door hold alarm will go off you
know emergency only push in case of
emergency and Chris Hayes said well yeah
it's very confusing oh yeah who could
possibly know what is meant by the sign
emergency exit only alarm will sound
push only in case of emergency it's just
so confusing I don't hm so ambiguous but
what's really funny is this one picture
going around of the supposedly confusing
signs is not what the congressman saw we
can see clearly on camera there's no
sign directly in front of that door he
he doesn't even look straight at the
door he turns to the left and pulls the
fire alarm so it's just a total it's a
total
farce the the reason that the Democrats
are scrambling here is not because Jamal
Bowman accidentally pulled a fire alarm
it's that he accidentally got
caught he I remember one time I was at
the University of Missouri Kansas City
this was early on in my campus tour life
and I was giving a speech called and
other uncomfortable truths this was
actually even before the issue really
hit the national stage but the libs were
already completely crazy about it so I
gave this speech other uncomfortable
truths and some wacko antifa type guy
busts in a fire door and sprays me with
some unknown substance no one no one
wants to know what it is and I look over
luckily there had been a cop right
behind the door and the cop gets this
guy down on the ground within about 10
seconds eventually he starts tasing the
guy cuz the guy was fighting back
against the cop and I looked into this
kid's face this antifa guy who was 18 19
something like that and the look on his
face it was one not of anger it was one
not of hatred it was one of just pure
shock that he had been
caught he he just was so shocked to face
any consequences for his actions and I
think that's exactly what's going on
with Bowman here I think that's exactly
what's going on with AOC and all the
rest of the Democrats they're just
shocked that for once they're being held
accountable for their actions because
they forgot that Kevin McCarthy at least
for now is the speaker of the house and
they forgot that there's security camera
footage and they forgot that sometimes
on rare
occasions they get outed for committing
crimes and obstructing official
proceedings and doing exactly the same
stuff that when the the right- Wingers
do it they call it a coupa the worst
Insurrection in history now speaking of
getting caught the house oversight
committee has just
discovered some proof I think pretty
clear proof that Joe Biden himself was
on the take from foreign countries
selling American influence the house
ofite committee has found that China
wired
$260,000 to Joe Biden's house now how do
we know this we know this because the
money didn't go to Joe Biden the money
went to Hunter Biden but the address
that was on file for the wire was Joe
Biden's
house now this means at the very
best the the most charitable read of
this is that Hunter would just happened
to be living with Joe shortly after Joe
announced his candidacy in 2019 this is
just a few months after Joe said I am
running for president over quar million
dollars shows up to Joe's house but it
was just because Hunter happened to be
there and it was all a big
misunderstanding and Joe didn't know
nothing about it but it just doesn't it
just unfortunately doesn't look great
now the reason that this doesn't work is
because the bidens have consistently
lied about every single aspect of this
story which we'll get to in in a second
though but if you don't have a quarter
million dollars in wire transfers just
random randomly showing up at your house
you're probably going to want to protect
some of your assets with Birch gold
right now text olds to 98 9898 last
month the group of 20 the G20 announced
a plan to impose digital currencies and
digital IDs on their populations Central
Bank digital currencies essentially
allow the government to track every
purchase you make officials could even
prohibit you from purchasing certain
products and easily freeze or Seize Your
Money concerned Americans are
diversifying their assets into physical
gold with the help of Birch gold if you
want a physical asset held in a tax
shelter retirement account you should
call Birch gold to text nolles kwl to 98
9898 and they will send you a free info
kit on gold the easiest way to become a
Birch gold customer is if you have an
IRA or 401K from a previous employer
just Gathering dust Birch gold can help
you convert it into an IRA in gold and
you don't pay a penny out of pocket text
nolles Canada to 98 9898 claim your free
info kit on gold and call them because
if digital currency becomes a reality
it'll be nice to have some gold to fall
back on right now 98 98 998 text nolles
money from
China showing up at the very least we
can say at the very leas to Hunter Biden
which directly contradicts what Hunter
Biden previously told us on National
Television the president has repeatedly
said that you received $
1.5 billion dollar from China despite no
experience and for no apparent reason
obviously fact Checkers have said that
that is not true look this is literally
has no basis in fact in any way have you
received any money from that business
dealing no at all not one cent not one
cent no no not one cent I rece I
received a lot of cents I received
$260,000 worth of cents but I did not
receive one single sent Joe Biden then
goes on and denies this as president
China compromised by your family's
business relationship Mr President Mr
President there
is
you is your presidency compromised by
your family's business
dealings give me a break man what are
you talking about they don't get that
many quarter million dollar payments
directly to my house what are you
talking about come on man so after he
dismisses this his press secretary Ken
Shan Pierre denies it but she's a little
softer she is a little more circumspect
in the way that she denies this house
oversight says they've got bank records
showing a Chinese Energy company paying
three Biden family members through a
third party what were they paid for look
I'm I'm just not going to respond to
that from here look we have heard from
House Republicans for years and years
and years um how uh how the inaccuracies
and lies when it comes to this issue and
I don't even where to begin to even
answer that question because again it's
been lies and lies and inaccuracy for
the past couple years and I'm just not
going to get into it from here there are
there are so many lies there are so many
lies I'm not going to name what those
lies are but there are so many lies that
I'm not going to answer this accusation
which I'm not going to directly call a
lie because it's obviously true but lies
lies lies la la
la la la I can't hear you but now we
know that 260 Grand at least coming from
bhr Partners
Associates uh which is bankrolled by the
Bank of China which is all deeply meed
with the Chinese Communist Party sent
that money to Hunter listing Joe Biden's
Delaware home as the beneficiary address
for the
funds can we really say though can we
and charity say Well it it was really
just for Hunter Joe probably didn't
know
you can't forget about separating Hunter
you can't separate any of the Biden
family from this issue because on top of
the revelations about Hunter on top of
the revelations about Joe Biden's
Delaware home address we now have the
New York Post reporting that Hunter
Biden's daughter Naomi 29-year-old Naomi
Biden was working on behalf of a foreign
government representing a foreign
government as a lawyer around the same
time that she was living at the White
House why do we think the government of
Peru hired Naomi Biden to represent it
do we think it's because I don't want to
I don't want to bisch Naomi's
scholarship and legal career something
tells me though as a 29-year-old lawyer
she's probably not all that accomplished
yet even if she were a good lawyer so
why would the government of Peru hire
Naomi Biden this random 29-year-old
lawyer to to represent it might it have
something to do with her last name might
it have something to do with the fact
that she was living in the white house
around the time she was working for
them it's a family business in in that
way this is like the Trump organization
they're they're very the Trump
organization and the Biden organization
are very different in that the Trump
organization even working in real estate
in New York with a lot of shady
characters the Trump organization is
basically on the up and up and the Biden
organization is pure influence
pedaling because Donald Trump did not
serve in government until 2017 Donald
Trump for all the shadiness that goes
into doing any kind of serious business
in New York Donald Trump was working in
the private sector Joe Biden has made
every penny that he's ever made
practically working in government at a
very high level of government because
he's been in the Senate since the early
1970s so the only way that he and his
family have made any money at all is by
selling American influence but they're
both family businesses do you remember
when Donald Trump got elected there was
a call for him to put his business in a
blind trust or to to divest from his
business divest for how is Donald Trump
going to divest from the Trump
organization the business is
Trump he could dissolve the whole
business or this this judge in New York
this Democrat judge that's trying to get
Trump they could dissolve the whole
business it wouldn't matter he is the
business he could start another one
called Trump organization to Electric
Baloo and it would be the same thing
because the business is him and his name
and his reputation well the same is true
for the
bidens Joe Biden is the guy with the
influence Hunter Biden is the one who
pedals that influence overseas in
Ukraine in China and elsewhere Naomi
Biden is another one who the
granddaughter of Joe daughter of Hunter
is another one who pedals that influence
overseas in Peru Frank Biden Joe's
brother is another one who pedals that
influence Frank Biden it's being
reported now by the New York Post Frank
Biden openly refers to Joe as the big
guy you remember in all those Hunter
Biden text messages and emails where
where we read about 10% for the big guy
or given half to the big guy well the
big guy Frank Biden admits is his
brother Joe Biden how about James Biden
Joe Biden's other brother he made every
penny to his name practically pedling
Joe's influence too that's the family
business and you can't separate it which
means that when we see quar million
dollar payments more than quar million
doll payments going to Hunter we know
that Joe's
involved Hunter wouldn't have any of
those payments if not for Joe and by the
way Joe's home address is the one
listed for the beneficiary line on the
payments speaking of Democrat Party
corruption there is someone running for
president against Joe Biden right now
who seeks to take on not only the
Republican party but corruption within
the Democrat Party how's he going to do
it it Bobby Kennedy Jr alludes to his
future plans hi everybody I'm going to
be in Philadelphia on October 9th to
make a major announcement at the very
birthplace of our nation I'm not going
to tell you right now exactly what that
announcement will be I can say though
that if you've been waiting to come to
one of my public events this will be the
one to come to I'll be speaking about a
SE change in American politics and what
your part and my part is in that had
change a lot of Americans who had
previously given up any hope that real
change would ever come through the
American electoral process have begun to
find New Hope in my candidacy and I
understand the deeply felt concern that
people have about the way
corruption has overtaken our government
it's in the executive branch it's in
Congress it's in the leadership of both
political parties and so some people
feel a kind of cynicism alongside the
hope or they lose hope entirely because
they've been disappointed so many times
I want to tell you now what I've come to
understand after 6 months of campaigning
there is a path to
Victory there is a path to Victory and
that path to Victory is going to be
running third party presumably that is
presumably he might surprise us but that
is probably what this announcement is
which is Raising some concerns on the
right because there are some people on
the right who have spent the last 6
months building more than that the last
year or more building up Bobby Kennedy
Jr who is a liberal he's a basically
amiable liberal he's clearly an
intelligent man but he's a big lib
that's why I've never been all that
gung-ho about the Bobby Kennedy
candidacy is I think okay he he's good
on coid he was one of the few of us who
early on called the coid nonsense but
he's wrong on abortion and he's wrong on
guns and he's wrong on a lot of aspects
of our constitutional order and he's a
big lib so I'm not going to I'm just not
going to support him not saying he's the
worst guy in the world I'm just saying
he and I have very different priorities
but there have been a lot of
conservatives who have really taken a
shine to
Kennedy because one he was right on coid
two he's taking on Joe Biden and the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and three
I think there are still a lot of
conservatives
who are basically kind of liberal they
just think the left has gone too far you
know they say I I was a Democrat and I
didn't leave my party my party left me
and all this woke stuff and all this
weird sex stuff it's gone way too far so
I can't go all the way with those
radicals or I can't be a socialist or I
can't be like an AOC but I'm still kind
of a Democrat and so they long for the
days of a Kennedy you look even at the
way that Bobby Kennedy is dressing he's
wearing those nice skinny ties from the
1960s he's trying to evoke his father
and his uncle John F Kennedy and that
that time before the Democratic party
had gone completely insane still I think
this hurts Democrats more Bobby Kennedy
is still polling at something like 19%
in the Democrat Party I think once the
reality of his political positions comes
out I don't think that the likely
Republican nominee Donald Trump is going
to have much of a hard time prying back
the types of conservatives who's sort of
like Bobby Kennedy back from him back
toward Trump and so all all in all I'm
I'm kind of for it I think that if if
Bobby Kennedy is going to be a third
party spoiler in this race I think he's
going to be more Ralph nater than he
will be Ross perau I think he's going to
hurt the Democrats more than the
Republicans probably but it remains an
open question now you know Kennedy wants
to look good by putting on those skinny
ties when you want to look good you got
to check out Jus cell right now go to
genucell.com it is no secret that we
here at the daily wire love the genus
Cell Dark Spot Corrector now you might
be asking what this product even does
well do you have sunspots brown spots
discoloration or dry skin pretty much
everyone does with the genus Cell Dark
Spot Corrector you can watch those
blemishes disappear in front of your
very eyes Kimberly from Youngstown Ohio
says my skin has improved so much since
using Jus cell on my face I love all my
genus sell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but this sale is ending very
soon take advantage of Jus cell's most
popular package which includes the Dark
Spot Corrector plus the classic genell
bags and puffiness treatment and
immediate effects for almost
77% off genus cell is so confident in
their products that you can try them for
yourself completely risk-free if you
don't see results in one day you'll get
your money back go to genucell.com
start looking years even decades younger
tomorrow say hello to the best skin that
you've ever had jus.com
genucell.com
slns woke candy companies think that
Franken Stein can become his own bride
which is why we launched Jeremy's
chocolate with he him and she her bars
only one of which has nuts we need to
sell more of this chocolate so we can
hire better copywriters around no I'm
joking I like the Frankenstein line our
domination over big chocolate is not
over not by a long shot just in time for
Halloween we are proud to introduce
Jeremy's chocolate in micro aggression
size what better way to share your
values than handing out our chocolates
taken down the leftists one
microaggression size bite at a time go
to Jeremy chocolate.com order yours
today in the meantime before we can
unseat Joe Biden Biden is ruthlessly
imposing his agenda you want to hear you
want to hear the perfect example of the
way Biden is tossing his power around
right now there's a German family that
is living in the United States that
actually sought political Asylum we hear
all the time about how the millions and
millions of illegal aliens crossing our
Southern border they're actually
political Asylum Seekers when they're
not they're mostly fighting age young
men who are economic migrants who just
want to make more money in the United
States very very few actual political
Asylum Seekers relative to the number of
illegals crossing the border in this
case we have a German family that did in
fact seek political Asylum because they
are Christians they're Evangelical
Protestants who wanted to homeschool
their kids didn't want to send their
kids to crazy German public schools that
were going to indoctrinate them and fill
their heads with all sorts of Lies so
homeschooling is practically illegal in
Germany at least where they were they
come to the United States they've been
here for 15 years they're here in my own
state of
Tennessee with the government's blessing
they've flourished they've done well
they're gainfully employed they're they
have lots of kids they dress properly
they behave well they're law- abiding
they they did everything
right they didn't cross the border
illegally they're here with the
government's blessing
and Joe Biden is saying they got to be
deported Joe Biden is saying they got to
pack their bags get out of
here which means their kids are going to
have to go back to those insane schools
the parents said that when they sent
their kids to these public schools in
Germany their whole personalities
changed they suffered health issues
while attending the public school
and any ordinary American knows that
that sort of thing happens because of
the nonsense that is taught in schools
and the deleterious that that nonsense
has on
kids they got to pack
up if this family were Venezuelan rather
than German they would be allowed to
stay they would be called they would be
called Dreaming future brighteye doey
American
dreamers if this family were not a
family but just a pack of young fighting
age men from
Honduras who crossed the border
illegally paid off the cartels were
involved in all sorts of crime they'd be
allowed to stay they're just dreamers
they're just they're just seeking a
better life
here if this family were liberal rather
than
conservative if this family were secular
rather than
Evangelical if this family were inclined
to vote Democrat rather than Republican
they would be called a wonderful
blessing of diversity to our nation to
show us the way
into toward progress and they would be
allowed to
stay but because they are German
Evangelical conservative white family
homeschoolers they got to go they're the
enemy according to the Biden
Administration and the reason for this
is that politics is not
abstract there are some conservatives
some very naive squishy conservatives
who believe that politics is totally
abstract and it's just about principles
floating in thin air which is why the
height of their political commentary and
activism is to huff and puff and throw
their hands up and say imagine if the
shoe were on the other foot and to say
well can you imagine if the rules were
reversed and to say this is UN this is a
double standard that's all they do I try
not I point out the hypocrisy when I can
but I also try to go a little further
than that because the Democrats know
that they know that it's unfair they
know that they're that they're playing
with two standards here
they know what the Democrats know that
the conservatives need to figure out is
that politics is not abstract politics
is always about real particular people
and real particular groups of
people German homeschooler Evangelical
conservative family that's the
enemy they get
deported Venezuelan economic migrant
don't speak a lick of English don't know
anything about our culture easy to
manipulate easy to control hooked on the
welfare system inclined to vote Democrat
at least generations down the line
they're the friend of this
Administration and our broader liberal
regime that's how it
works horn hat guy gets a private tour
around the capital escorted by police
officers he's the enemy he's an
insurrectionist he's doing a coup d'a he
goes to prison for 41 months Jamal
Bowman pulls a fire alarm and it would
seem likely to me intentionally
obstructs an official Congressional
proceeding oh he just didn't know he
can't read signs you expect a member of
Congress to know how to read you expect
a member of Congress to to have the the
functional IQ of a fourth grader and to
know what what words mean in in syntax
in order when it says emergency exit
only push only if you want the alarm to
ring oh he couldn't know that or more
likely he of course he did know that and
he just didn't think he'd get caught
well he's a friend he doesn't even get a
slap on the
wrist that's how it
works and as long
as Democrats continue to acknowledge the
particular character of politics and
conservatives just think it's all
abstract principles floating in thin air
applying equally to
everybody we're going to continue to
lose we want principles and the ultimate
principle that we want is justice but
the way to get Justice in politics is
not to bury our heads in the sand and to
pretend that politics is practiced other
than as it is it's to recognize that it
is really about groups of people and
teams and alliances when AOC refuses to
throw Bowman under the bus even though
we got him dead to rights we got him on
camera it's clear as day that guy did it
she
doesn't she doesn't throw them under the
bus because they're on the same team and
in order to do anything in politics you
need to have teammates and alliances and
compatriots and you need to work
together
that's what we're seeing
here so they're going to deport the
German we're going to say well okay but
now you better Deport all those economic
migrants who are very likely to vote for
Democrats and who aren't Evangelical
homeschoolers yeah they're not going to
do that they're not going to do that so
what now every Republican should be
pushing to allow this family to stay
this family is exact this is the exact
type of family that should be granted
asylum in the United States Christians
fleeing religion
persecution in Europe where we don't
even take that many European immigrants
anymore the vast overwhelming majority
of immigrants that we take in are from
Latin America so if you want any kind of
fairness in our immigration system
surely you would say okay one of the
underrepresented groups that don't
really immigrate to the United States or
are not really allowed in maybe we
should allow them in every Republican
should be clamoring to let this family
stay with political Asylum speaking
of specific people
there's a race on for who replaces Diane
Feinstein in the US Senate Diane
Feinstein uh died last week Senator
Feinstein lived a very long life you
know it's it it's always sad when people
die because death is is just a sad thing
but you know she didn't flip her
Corvette at age 22 she lived until the
ripe old age of 90 or thereabouts she
served in the Senate until her last day
uh she had a largely distinguished
career in as much as even conservatives
kind of like Herz she wasn't the
craziest lib in the whole US Senate and
now now there's a question of who's
going to replace her Gavin Nome who
clearly wants to run for president the
California governor and needs to pick
someone but the problem is there's
already a race on for her seat because
she wasn't running for re-election so
the top candidates to replace her are
already running that's Katie Porter US
Representative Barbara Lee US
Representative and Adam Schiff he's us
rep too so it's three members of
Congress running to replace her
if Gavin Newsome picks any one of them
he will be seen as giving an unfair
advantage in the election which is
happening just next
year plus he's he's got got an identity
politics mindfield here he's got white
lady ktie Porter but she's popular with
the Dems uh Barbara Lee a black lady so
if he picks the white lady over the
black lady that's going to be called
racist if he picks the black lady over
the white lady that's going to be called
tokenism but he'd probably be be able to
get away with that more easily and then
Adam Schiff who's a white man very very
bad but he's a very prominent Democrat
he's probably the most de prominent
Democrat of any of them and he ran the
impeachment against Donald Trump so Dems
like him he's got to pick someone um
hold
on gav I am hearing from my producers
Gavin Newsome has already picked a
replacement and let see I've got it let
me pull up my
text okay I sort of had wished that I
had checked the mail or checked the news
rather before for this show uh okay Nome
picks lefa Butler as Feinstein's
replacement this is from Politico
California's governor chose a labor
leader to in power player to serve in
the Senate an adviser told Politico
there were no preconditions about
whether or not she could run in 2024
very interesting so this person could
run again but he but this is very smart
of New Look Nome man this guy is a very
very sharp political player
because he just got it done right away
there's no guessing aame there's no
jockeying he just immediately appointed
somebody he probably had this person on
Deck the moment that Senator Feinstein
got sick uh check some of the identity
politics boxes I think lefon Butler it
said is a lesbian I could be wrong about
that if I'm just making that up sorry to
do that but she uh she is a black woman
they're making a big deal about so
anyway it checks off some identity
politics boxes and uh just takes the
issue off off the table so now the rest
of them can duke it out and Nome can
focus on what he wants to focus on which
is potentially running for president who
is going to replace Senator Feinstein
there's a there's a fourth option
because nome's theoretically got to pick
someone who's not already running and I
did look I'm just reading the news so
I'm just telling you what is being
reported this is from The Daily
Mail Megan Markle is considering a run
for
office the former Duchess of Sussex
the biological weapon that I think was
made in an American laboratory somewhere
as as a bioweapon to destroy the British
crown we just sent her over there like a
heat seeking missile she found Harry and
then tried to blow up the monarchy
anyway
she could theoretically maybe be
considered to be picked I don't I don't
buy it but Megan Markle is apparently
gunning for it Megan Markle has
reportedly cultivated a lot of political
I contacts on the left she is close
friends with Gloria steinm the first
first lady of feminism in the United
States Gloria steum huge force in
Democrat Party politics a friend of
Gloria steum has said that Gloria has
been introducing Megan to pivotal people
within the party according to this
report Megan is interested in politics
more than anything else and that's where
she believes her power is but she's had
to focus on making money this story this
really puts monarchists in a tough spot
doesn't it there there are some people
in America who are monarchists who are
just open avowed monarchists and they're
usually very buttoned up very
conservative sort of people and this is
now the best shot to get a royal into a
position of power in the United States
maybe that we've ever had and it just so
happens that the Royal is this awful
American actress who is seems
ideologically opposed to monarchy and
tries to destroy it and is a big lib I
don't know what the monarchists are
supposed to do here puts them in a very
very difficult spot also an amazing
journey this woman was an actress she
became a
princess but she didn't want to be the
she didn't want to be the real thing she
didn't want to be an actual princess she
wanted to leave being a princess to
pretend to be a princess on TV but then
she didn't want to just play pretend on
TV she wants to be in Democratic
politics what an amazing journey of
dissatisfaction that I assume will just
never
end because it's a feature of modern
liberal life that you're just never
satisfied with your station in life
speaking of diluted women livs of Tik
Tok has just found a video of probably
I'm not allowed to keep this on a
certain social media
website Libs of Tik Tok has
found a a perfect example of the illogic
undering
[Music]
the
my favorite comment on Friday is from
Bryce n laner 1216 who
says you're focusing on the effect not
the cause if you want things to get
better you have to find out why they are
oh no that's not that wasn't my favorite
comment I'm gonna pull my actual
favorite comment my favorite comment
let's see I pulled it up on my I'm gonna
have to kill Professor Jacob for getting
that comment wrong the my actual
favorite comment is let me see
because it was a good one and I waited
to to tell this joke here it is I wonder
if Diane Feinstein is going to seek
re-election and vote for Biden next year
and the reason I wanted that to be the
comment is
because when the senator sadly passed
away my my first thought was okay that's
sad you know because she lived a good
long life I don't think any of us
thought she was long for this world um
can I make the joke on the show that
that while she has died and gone on to
her Eternal reward uh it's unclear if
she has resigned her seat in the Senate
and I talked to my producers and I
talked to sweet little Alisa and they
said it's too soon it's important you
can't make that joke on that day and so
I said I'm not going to make that I
didn't think it was disrespectful but I
said I'm not going to make that joke out
of difference to but now someone else
has made it it's several days later I
think it's an open question forget about
Senator Feinstein for a second Joe Biden
I'm not convinced the man has a pulse
he's not resigned the presidency and I
don't think he would for many
months in if such an event God forbid
were to occur it's a question maybe
they'll just all stick it out maybe
we'll just have Boomer and Silent
generation political
leaders
forever speaking of unbelievable
things Nikki Haley has claimed that the
Trump campaign has
sent a a prank of some sort to her hotel
room
Nikki says after a day of campaigning
this is the message waiting for me
outside my hotel room # pretty pathetic
try again # you just made my case for
me and it's I didn't get this at first
it's a bird cage and it says from Trump
campaign and it has bird feed on top of
it and I had some people immediately
said I don't believe that this really
happened but I just couldn't even
understand what the joke was and then I
found out apparently Trump has called
her a bird brain but I don't he hasn't
done it all that prominently so I don't
like like I follow these things pretty
closely and the fact that
that uh
Illusions just passed right by me and I
didn't catch it I don't know I just did
it didn't seem very credible and I I
don't know why would the Trump campaign
sign it from Trump
campaign it just seems ridiculous so now
people are calling Nikki uh Nikki smette
and they're
saying I don't
think she's lying I don't think Nikki
would just brazenly lie about this I
don't think it's real I don't think the
Trump campaign actually sent that to her
but I don't know this would be very this
would be very strange for Nikki haly to
just stage the whole thing and may maybe
some member her of her campaign did I
just find it very hard to believe Nikki
haly is a pretty serious person I find
it very hard to believe that she would
come up with this Jesse Smet kind of
hoax and Stage it and so I I don't
really buy that uh but at the same time
I don't think this happened I don't the
whole thing to me seems kind
of like a sideshow but then so much of
the GOP Primary is a sideshow
because even if you love Nikki and
you're campaigning for Nikki even if you
love Tim Scott you're campaigning for
Tim Scott even if you love Ronda Santa
it is simply a
fact the race has not changed at all not
one iota in about 15 months now and
we're not just talking about one poll or
you question the ABC Washington Post
poll or this poll none of the polls
they've all remained almost exactly
where they've been for 15 months and the
gap between the number one candidate and
the number two 3 four five and six
candidate is
huge
so is there any chance of these guys
dropping out is there any chance for
instance of Ronda Santa saying I'm going
to shut shutter The Campaign and agree
to be Trump's VP Maria bomo just asked
Governor DeSantis that here's his answer
if president Trump came to you and said
let's partner up you be my VP would you
do it no I'm I'm running for president
we need somebody that can serve two
terms we need somebody that can win
States like Georgia and Arizona which
president Trump cannot do or did not do
even though candidates like McCain and
Romney had no problem winning those
States we need somebody who and I'm the
only one running incl including Donald
Trump everything I've promised the
voters that I would do as governor of
Florida I've delivered on and then
Governor desandis goes into the stump
speech and says no I'm running hardcore
I'm only going for the top job I will
not be the VP I think this is probably
smart for disantis this was the right
answer he could have perhaps been the VP
though probably not because Trump is
running as a
Floridian so just actually the way our
constitution sets up the race you can't
have a a president and a vice president
pres from Florida practically speaking
the electoral vote wouldn't work that
way um or or you couldn't have a
president vice president from the same
state period uh but let's say I don't
know let's say Trump ran as a New York
candidate or something like that he had
residency in New York could DeSantis
have been his VP yeah yeah probably had
he just endorsed Trump early on and said
I'm not going to run for president cut a
deal since he was the most formidable
and Remains the most formidable
Challenger to Trump in the race yeah
maybe but it's too late for that it's
too late and so if DeSantis were trying
to get a VP spot or even some senior
cabinet spot he probably Trump would
just toy with him the way that he toyed
with Mitt Romney and then degrade him
and humiliate him and Des Santa says I
don't want to be degraded and humiliated
so no I'm going to run for the top spot
the die is cast and if it kills my
political career so be it I'm going to
be the alternative to Donald Trump there
is a question because DeSantis has not
been able to close that Gap should there
be another alternative to Donald Trump
and there is a big move of put to draft
Glenn yunen Glenn yunen is meeting with
conservative donors uh in just a matter
of weeks now this would be a last minute
entry into the race if it were at all
possible uh they will be
meeting on October 17th for the red vest
Retreat there he is if if Nikki's not
going to do it if DeSantis isn't going
to do it if Tim's not going to do it
there's our last hope we who hate Donald
Trump we are going to get Glenn
yunan he would be crazy to do it he
would be crazy to do it I don't think he
will I think he's too smart a a
politician but if you're Glenn yunan
first of all you're so lat to the race
already you've missed major
opportunities to fund raise for years
now at this point I mean Donald Trump
already had such an advantage on the
other candidates which I think accounts
for some of his his spot in the polls
but even the other candidates have been
raising money and out there campaigning
Glen yunan hasn't done any of that he's
going to enter the race at the very last
minute after having seen what happened
to D santis maybe the most promising
young Republican in the party certainly
in years who basically just got pushed
off to the side by Trump and Nikki and
Tim and forget about Chris Christie
forget about Doug berham but there are a
lot of people who are really serious
contenders who just got pushed to the
side and you're Glenn yunan and you're
going to say okay I'm I'm a popular
Governor right now but I'm going to
throw away my political career to try to
challenge Trump at the last minute and
probably
lose I don't think so I I think what the
these stories tell you is
more more indicative of the fact that
the anti-trump part of the
GOP is is beginning to feel the heat
beginning to get a little bit desperate
because their options are not working
out the rest of the show continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member use code n scan Wes check it for
2 months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
yeah